[Music]
hello everyone and welcome to tonight's
episode of beginner breakdown my name is
Alex mulling and tonight we're going to
do something a little different now
we're going to be talking about tactics
and puzzles and I've done that before
that's not the different part but
tonight the difference is we're just
doing it live so uh instead of me kind
of preparing and pulling things together
that I think are going to be useful
whether to work on a specific tactic
like a pin or a fork um or just talking
about you know tactical signals or
positional analysis we're just going to
be doing a bunch of puzzles and the
point of this is there there's two main
reasons the the first one is I think
it's just a common activity people like
to do puzzles and so I want to talk you
through my approach to it uh and the
other thing is just understanding how
someone looks out for tactics in any
given position and so how you can apply
this not only to just doing puzzles but
also for your own games of Chess so the
first example is already on the screen
all of these again are not curated by me
it's so I could get it wrong and that'll
be a learning experience too um but when
you look at a position like this I want
you to take notice of a few things uh we
will be uh I'm going to kind of walk us
through the first handful of them and
then we're going to just kind of Let it
Loose to the people in the live audience
and the twitch chat to what your
suggestions are and what you think we
should be uh noticing but when I look at
a position the first thing that's maybe
a bit of a problem with a puzzle from a
learning perspective is you know this is
just some random position right I I this
is not something that I might find in my
own game and I know there's an answer
right it it's presented to me on this
website that there's an answer to this
puzzle there's a best move that lets me
win or in some weird cases lets me force
a
draw and in a real game I don't know
those guarantees for sure so the first
first thing you want to do is kind of
get accustomed to the position you want
to say what's going on here what are the
important things to notice and there's a
few things I like to look at first kind
of the very first thing I look for is
material so um sometimes on the website
it'll have like a little plus one or
plus two for one side being a material
but it's always safe just to count so
here 1 two 3 four five six seven pawns
for White against one 2 3 four 5 six
seven pawns for black so pawns are even
those cancel out both sides have a
knight both sides have a queen both
sides have a king and both sides have
two Rooks so we can cancel everything
out so material is dead equal okay so
the first thing I know is okay I'm I'm
doing okay material yes is
iten it is but we'll talk about why in a
second because there's a few other
important things in this position so
first we looked at the material and the
second thing I looked out for is
tactical signals now I've done a few
videos on different tactical signals and
I encourage you to check them out um but
the main things I'm going to be looking
out for here and just kind of The quick
summary version is one king position and
especially King safety two uh alignments
so anytime I see pieces lined up in the
same row something like this as well um
and kind of like KN Fork distance so if
there are pieces that I could drop a
knight on the board and it would Fork
multiple pieces then that's something I
notice as well um and so those kinds of
things and if we come into any others
like trap pieces or more specifics we
can talk about them as they come up um
so we're going to be looking for those
signals and we're also looking at you
know just important things to notice
about the position so I notied that this
Knight is undefended and attacked right
that's something I should be aware of
now a few people in the chat have
suggested and in our live audience but
the move here is Queen takes
D4 I'm pretty sure we're going to find
out leeches might tell me I'm wrong
that's our move now if you didn't
understand why that was the move that's
okay and there's going to be a followup
for it but the first thing I noticed in
this position besides the material and
the kind of like the hanging Knight and
those things is I notice that the king
and Rook are in Fork distance right um
they're right next to each other and if
I could put a knight on E6 for example I
would get a fork now we encounter an
immediate problem with that if we try
and play Knight to E6 right away the
problem well there's a night guarding
that square so we're just going to lose
that piece and it's just a trade now
again materials equal so maybe that's
not the end of the world but whenever
you see an opportunity like a puzzle you
know we should be looking for some
advantage or something better than just
equality most of the time so the next
question is well we want to play this
move it looks really good and then we
and then you can even notice oh it's not
just forking these pieces it's also
forking the queen so now that tells us
if I can find a way to get rid of this
Knight even if I have to lose a queen to
do it then I'm going to get a queen back
and that's why Queen takes D4 as our
move we sacrifice the
queen and black recaptures cuz what else
they've lost a knight and it's check so
recaptures and we can follow it up with
now Knight to E6 because there is no
more Knight guarding that square and we
can finish it off by taking the queen
and that's kind of the process of very
good doing these puzzles
um the last thing I want to mention
before I move too far on is something
else I find really helpful if you're the
kind of person who again like if you
just like doing puzzles great you want
to do puzzle rush you want to kind of
run through it that's totally fine
nothing wrong with that if you're the
kind of person who wants to do puzzles
in order to get better at chess just
generally and you are struggling you
know with some of the things I brought
up before about well I'm not going to
know in a real game if I'm in a puzzle
situation or not one of the nice things
you can do uh like at least on leeches
here and I think on some other websites
too is you can actually go back in time
in the game so I can see what moves were
played that led up to this moment and in
fact on less I can go all the way back
to the very beginning right I can go to
the very beginning of this
game and play it
through now you might not play moves
this way but at least doing this might
give you some of that context and that
feel like oh if you take it a little
step at a time and say okay so what's
going on in this position why are both
sides playing the moves they're playing
and trying to understand it when you get
to that puzzle position and we're going
to Speed
Ahead now we're a little closer we see
okay so black moves their Queen to
attack our Knight we push our Pawn with
a discovered check black moves the king
and we reached our puzzle position this
can help you out a little bit if you're
really struggling with just jumping into
some random position and want to
understand the context a little more
okay let's move on to our next example
here in this position it is black to
move you can know that because we see
the kind of coloration of this Square it
means that a piece was on this square
and The Rook is the other one so The
Rook moved from this Square to this
Square you can also do that by kind of
walking back and forth through the game
like we did before now in this position
there's something else that I notice
right away and that is the phase of the
game because unlike the previous
position this is very clearly an end
game there's not a lot of pieces left on
the board uh it's really only the Rooks
and kings are the only major pieces left
and then some pawns so we have different
tasks and goals in an end game that we
might in a middle game right in a middle
game we want our Kings to be farther
away from the action most of the time be
safe in an end game the Kings need to be
an important part of the fight so that's
already telling us some information we
also know that in end games if we have
either an advantage in material or in
this case I'm not noticing we have a
past Pawn right here that could be
valuable right I don't actually know the
answer to this one yet I've just looked
at it um but in my mind if we can get
the Rooks off the board then this might
be a path to Victory is walking this
Pawn home again not so sure it's a
little more complex than
that and so the question is if I want to
promote a pawn and I see an opportunity
to trade Rooks or win material that's
what I should be looking for so with all
of that in mind does anyone have any
suggestions for what we should do here
as black
okay Rook F3 what's your
idea what is your idea with Rook to
F3 it is Czech but in remember in a end
game Czech isn't for its own sake
usually so good right cuz the king
doesn't mind being forced to move around
so we only want to call check if if it's
helping us with something
else is this move helping with anything
else not
sure well someone in the chat suggested
it too um and it was actually the first
move I've seen and my thought is there's
something in there's an alignment going
on here of this King and this Pawn this
Pawn is a backwards Pawn it's
unsupported by anything else and if we
can get rid of it we now have created
two past pawns for ourselves so that
seems pretty
useful Rook to F3 check threatens to
play Rook takes C3 on the next move
which seems really good right winning a
pawn in a chess game is already good if
you can win a pawn in an end game that's
sometimes the difference between winning
and losing so this looks good and this
is what I would qualify as a forcing
move so again a forcing move there I've
done a few lectures on this as well but
the short and sweet version is it's any
move that forces your opponent to
respond immediately now they can
sometimes have a number of options for
how to do that um but a check is a great
example because anytime you call check
the opponent has to respond to the check
they can't let their King stay in danger
sometimes they can move out of the way
sometimes they can take the piece that's
calling check or block it but they have
to do something about it and in this
case this is our forcing move what do
you think white is going to play
here
probably D2 right because they don't
want to lose the pawn so this is a good
forcing move if they go to uh probably
to E2 or to E4 the only other legal
moves then it seems reasonable that
we're just going to play Rook takes C3
and have two nice pass pawns and it will
be very hard for white to come back from
so it seems like after Rook to F3 the
king is going to go to D2 now the
question here with our forcing moves is
do we have any good follow-ups from
there
how might you continue from this
position yeah
mange the king the blacking can get the
because those on the F Poss
create yeah so I like the way you're
thinking here so we have another forcing
move right so we're going to play Rook
to F2 or Rook F3 check King goes to D2
and The Rook now moves to F2 with check
and the King has to move to C1 right if
it goes anywhere else or sorry from here
if it goes anywhere else than C1 then we
just win a rook um and we have the
option to exchange and your argument is
we should exchange because then we have
have like better pass pawns and um yeah
this makes a lot of sense to me the one
piece I'm a little concerned with is can
our King successfully infiltrate after
we trade Rooks like I'm looking at this
path and trying to think if this works
if we have time and are we in any danger
from these pawns because there is a pawn
majority against our one Pawn
here uh so there's a few things to think
about right I do think we're on the
right track it doesn't seem like there's
any other very clear way to make
progress so I like to generally when I
do a puzzle try and figure out the whole
thing in my head but in some more
complicated puzzles it's also okay just
to kind of give it your best shot once
you're pretty confident on the first
thing and you want to see how your
opponent responds so let's give it a try
and see if we're correct with Rook to F3
check King actually plays to
E4 so the the the computer probably just
does not like this end game of of
trading down and thinks it's just lost
um and here I'm going to guess we just
want to take this Pawn that seems like
the reason we played our
move and okay they push upon PA
here my instinct again we can take time
and probably if you're trying to get
rating on puzzles you should take more
time but uh it seems to me that we can
just take this maybe there's a check but
like I don't think they're winning
anything so I'm probably just going to
take this
yeah there's a check but again I don't
think they're winning anything so long
as we defend the pawn and the puzzle is
done now the other thing here that's
really important uh in this one is that
I wasn't one I wasn't 100% confident so
it was good to nice have our reasoning
confirmed but also he played a move that
we weren't expecting right the the line
that seemed the most difficult to prove
in my opinion was if the King goes back
this way and we trade Rooks cuz then I
have to calculate a king and pawn
endgame and make sure it works so if you
ever get to a situation like this and
the computer just says well everything
else is losing so I guess I'm playing
this move um I think it's always
important to go back and go through
those lines we missed so let's imagine
that this is played uh I can now my plan
is to turn on the computer and compare
it to what we said right because our
idea was we're going to play Rook to F2
we're going to either win The Rook or
exchange them and then our King's going
to try and infiltrate somewhere
computer says Rook to F2 is minus 8
everything else is about equal so Rook
to
F2 um here again I'm going to guess that
yeah King to C1 you have to play it and
again our our line um Rook to F1 also
works because we can force the trade to
happen again Rook to F1 is kind of a
funny computer move I think because it's
giving the opponent the most chances to
give us the Rook for free but if we're
going to assume our opponent is not not
a fool then probably is safe enough to
just take the
rook and here I am not going to turn on
the computer because we were kind of
debating two ideas uh at least in the
chat it seems one was to come this way
to B6 and A5 and either win or uh just
block blockade these pawns and the other
was the one I suggested first which was
to run this way and try and infiltrate
somewhere in the center and looking at
it more I'm actually siding a little
more myself with this B6 idea now
because white has too many things to do
initially I thought well if we go this
way then they can maybe just defend but
there's two problems is one we can waste
moves we can just play moves and
eventually their King is stuck they
can't defend this Pawn because our Pawn
covers this Square so if they ever like
let's just imagine something like this
happens if we just play a move they have
to move their king or or give up a pawn
the other problem is more simple it's
just well this Pawn is going you have to
stop it so they don't actually have time
to defend any of this uh because if we
run this
way they still have to deal with this
pawn and even if we let them get in
really far by this point it's too late
we've made another threat so I this
seems to be the right idea um now I will
again check with a computer to be sure
yeah King to B6 uh you can also just
push this Pawn right away and then
switch to this idea maybe even play King
to D5 but I don't think if you're doing
this you're trying to run this
way um yeah let's say they just go here
yeah uh we have to go back so that kind
of idea and again this is the kind of
thing where you don't have to have seen
all of this when you were prepping the
puzzle or working through it but I find
it really helpful to either confirm or
challenge my ideas about what I thought
the position was
more so than just oh I got the puzzle
right like that's great but also what if
they did something different okay here's
our next
puzzle we have another endgame puzzle
this one even more end gamey of an end
game very few pawns very few pieces just
one rook and one Pawn on each
side um now the benefit we have is our
Pawn is much closer right we are one
square from promotion blacks is
three does anyone have any ideas for
what we should
do um so elzach I actually don't know
the rating of these puzzles I I just
went to like a non signed in leeches
account um so it's whatever their
default one is I think they default to
like 1500 question mark so it's Pro and
I it's probably a little easier than
that I would
guess
all right so uh a few suggestions in the
chat the first one that most people are
saying is Rook to A8 and this is the
thing that also jumps to my mind right
it's a forcing move it's a check and it
puts our Rook on the right line to
defend the promotion Square once we
eventually push this Pawn I think that's
really important another thing with this
type of puzzle is I also will imagine if
in some strange world we like traded
everything down and traded the Rooks is
my king able to stop this Pawn am I in
the Box and in this case the answer is
no right we think about the boxes when
it's the king's trying to move if you
drew a a box from the pawn diagonally to
the edge of the board and you just kind
of make this box if the king can step
into it then he can catch the pawn so in
this case I know that uh there's no way
for me to catch this Pawn if it just
runs so we have to find another kind of
solution we can't just Bank on
that um but the suggestion is we check
and it's a forcing move so we think what
does the king play in this case only one
legal move we oops we cover every other
Square the king is going to have to go
to
H7 um and then yes from there we can
just see we actually don't even need to
promote the pawn as some people in the
chat have realized uh promoting the pawn
actually I think is probably lost so
let's walk through it and kind of talk
through how we got there check and
Checkmate if we had tried to promote the
pawn uh then the problem is black now
trades everything down and remember we
aren't close enough to catch the pawn so
we are going to be just one move too
short and actually lose this
game um so we were kind of Saved by that
Checkmate I originally thought the idea
might be we call some check and force
the king to like walk in front of the
rook's connection but it wasn't that
complicated because we're actually just
able to cover all of the relevant
squares and call a Checkmate so again
this is another example this happens a
lot with puzzles because they all you
know they can't just say oh here's a
position where you have 17 good moves
it's usually you have a good move maybe
you have a move that draws but probably
everything else is bad um and so a lot
of the time like very forcing moves like
checks or captures are the moves to look
out for there are ones with it quiet
moves but those are much more rare
usually much more advanced than often
because of that much
harder okay let's look at our next
position
here all right so feel free to suggest
moves but also feel free to just uh tell
me what you notice about the position
what seem like relevant factors for what
we should be looking for and considering
as we try and find the best move here
for
white uh yeah I think it probably is um
Cody real quick again the I'm not
entirely sure the specific rating
because all I've done is go into uh just
leeches on a unsigned in account like
I'm not signed in I'm just kind of on
the default browsing version and just
doing puzzles randomly there so it's
whatever its default setting is
too um but yeah so the we your
suggestion was Queen to G4 with what's
your idea check check I love the idea
how are you going to do
it
mhm and actually if the King goes to h8
it's checkm 2 right because our Knight
covers this Square so the things you
might notice when you look at this
position right again really quick just
to walk through we won't take take as
much time with all of them is what I
notice is we're in a middle game uh
right both sides are castled I notice
immediately that my opponent's Castle is
kind of wrecked right so King safety is
something that I want to watch out for
and this king is not safe as we can see
from we have a very clear
check the fact that our Knight is very
close to the king also contributes to
the king being not safe right it's not
just that they don't have pieces in the
way or defending it's also we have
pieces that are taking up space and
actively controlling areas and so that's
what allows this nice mate in
two um other things you might notice you
might notice the Knight is hanging but
again in chess when Tempo and forcing
moves are all that matters we don't have
to immediately take that into account we
can deal with it later and uh yeah so I
think King safety is really the big
thing here right one of the first things
you want to notice in any position is is
my king safe is my opponents and so we
got this nice Queen to G4 and again
doesn't matter where they went because
our Knight covers this square and its
Checkmate either
way all right here's our next
one it is White's turn to
move feel free to suggest moves but also
maybe even more helpfully feel free to
suggest uh just things you notice that
seem important in the
position all right elzach I like your
suggestion and Berliner same but why
what is it about that move you
like
yes very nice so a lot going on here but
we can let's break it down really simply
the move suggested by several people is
E5 and the nice thing about this is
right there's not a lot going on we have
red our King is cast then our Knight is
out um but most of our pieces are back
here so this is more of an opening
almost we would want to get them
developed but we have this nice tactical
opportunity we can play E5 and Fork the
bishop and Knight and so we're going to
win one of them for our Pawn now
whenever you look at a piece that is
attacked or defended or those types of
things I like to just count right so I
can say okay if I put my Pawn here it's
going to be defended once by my knight
and it's going to be attacked twice by
the bishop and queen normally that means
it's not defended enough right I'm
outnumbered but there's a bit of a trick
here because we also see there is an
alignment between the queen and the the
king that because they're on the same
line and because we are castled that if
we go through that forcing Exchange in
the center then we can finish it off by
sliding our Rook over and getting a pin
on the queen and so we will even if we
lose uh a little bit of material like a
Rook or the Knight or whatever we're
going to win the queen and that's going
to be well worth it so Pawn to E5 Bishop
takes Knight takes and queen takes Rook
to E1 and here no matter what you do um
your losing material
probably I don't know if it's better if
you're black here just to take the Rook
or like maybe there's an argument to
made of playing Knight to E4 um you're
still going to lose the material right
imagine they play Knight to E4 how might
you continue as
white PA yeah Pawn F3 looks very natural
maybe you might play like Knight here
too because you can always follow it up
with F3 but I think both are good
um yeah it doesn't this doesn't hurt
anything right there's no tricks of them
moving and there's no checks or anything
so just developing with some attacks I
think this all looks good and we're
eventually going to win this piece and
if Black's not careful um we might also
just win the queen
anyway um the other thing I notice here
is this is like very early in the game
so something I sometimes do is see was
this like an opening trap or did someone
make a blunder how did we get to this
position cu the puzzle started at move
seven so this is the kind of thing where
you might play through and say is this
the opening I play if you play E4 E5
which is very very common for white and
black you might say well let me take a
look and see if there something I play I
as white still play all of these
moves um I do not play the Italian or
the or sorry I don't play the Spanish or
the Roy Lopez so this is where it would
not be as applicable for me but it's
still good to know generally what
happened here so and if you do play you
would obviously want to know takes
takes Pawn to D3 and Bishop D4 and so I
see the pawn was kind of lured off of
this Square when the king castles and we
have this opportunity so may be a little
bit of a Miss of just white being very
rapid with their development uh
prioritizing getting the king safe and
being able to develop this Rook so again
if that's an opening you play on either
side it's going to be more relevant for
you to know what to try or what to avoid
perhaps um obviously again compare that
against computer and opening books but
something I like to take note of okay
let's jump to the next example
here all right this one it's white to
move Black's last move was Pawn G7 to G5
what do you notice what do you see and
I'll kind of talk through what I see as
well I'm noticing we're in a middle game
here um not quite an end game because
Queens are on the board and kings are
sort of trying to be
safe okay F takes G5 what's your
reasoning very good so we see there is
an alignment here and a hanging piece
right hanging pieces or unprotected
pieces another one of our tactical
signals we see this bishop is not
defended by anything we see this queen
is lined up with it so this looks like a
pin right the bishop is pinning the pawn
it shouldn't be able to move because
we're going to lose our Queen but
something I like to say is a bad pin is
just a discovery waiting to happen and
in this case this bishop is pinning but
it's not well supported and the fact
that we can move the piece that is
pinned with
check means that you have to deal with
the forcing threat and don't have time
to keep the bishop
alive
um yeah so we're going to get this piece
we might even win this one right it's
possible if you know black isn't careful
we might also win this one and the king
is still very very
exposed um what if King F7 instead of
Rook G5 that's a good question let's
take a look so if we take the pawn pawn
and this is the kind of thing you can
just play out but it's also helpful to
try and do it in your mind so F takes G5
and then the King goes to you said F7
some suggesting
E7 so F7 I think we still just take
because even if they take our Knight we
can then take their Bishop so we're
going to get these two pieces for this
one and maybe the pawn um King to E7
looks a little more concerning because
now they're defending the bishop so what
might we do against that we take and
they play King to
E7 are we in
trouble any ideas what do you think we
should
do
yeah Zach I like your thinking as well
as with Yan
Senor um the king notice on this square
right the problem we're maybe a little
worried about is in this position and
I'll just put it on the board now we
notice our Queen is attacked but our
Knight is also attacked right we have to
keep our Queen somewhere defending the
Knight so I think there's a few
reasonable moves um the one suggestion
that's coming from a few people is we
can play Knight to G6 check with which
frees the knight from
danger um there's again considerations
of well what if they move to attack it
but anytime they move their King out of
the way we're going to pick up the
bishop and even if they get the Knight
the thing to remember about this whole
variation is all of this started with us
taking this Pawn so like at the absolute
worst we just want a pawn at the
absolute worst so long as we don't give
up another piece but even if we wanted
to be you know more
careful uh you could just you know maybe
move the queen back out of the way
continue to defend the Knight
um this looks really enticing to me
because again it's forcing the king to
step away from this bishop and again we
have threats of maybe even winning a
second one so this seems quite
reasonable to me now again none of that
was part of the puzzle so I like to
confirm that with the computer if the
King goes to F7 then Knight to G6 now
interestingly Queen to F2 is not good
why is that
well okay taking another closer look
what's one of the first things I said we
should do is look at the material count
and we notice here Black's got a bishop
pair against our Knight so we want to
win something right we don't just want
to not let anything happen because if
they just take back the pawn then black
is quite happy so this makes a lot of
sense we want to play Knight to G6 to
force the king away we can
take and then if they take we're getting
another one so we win the piece back and
we're still in a really strong position
their King is in danger and if they
don't take our Knight like they move the
bishop somewhere maybe then okay well
then we just have apparently a mate in
two but even if we didn't you get the
idea okay our next example here new
puzzle okay weird first move so it's
black to move and we notice that Bishop
to C3 is played and it looks weird to me
because I'm like well that gets taken
but we know okay well there's some Rooks
lined up against us so we need to think
maybe it's not such a bad move but this
is also a puzzle so maybe it's not such
a good
move yeah Rook takes F5 from the
previous one is kind of kind of wild
computers are nutty don't always use
them I mean they're it's good
information but don't feel weird if you
don't like see all the moves the
computer
sees okay so what is important about
this
position uh again what I'm noticing is
let's start with the material here one
two 3 four five versus 1 two 3 four five
pawns are equal Knight versus Bishop two
Rooks versus two Rooks so it's dead even
just an imbalance of the Knight versus
the bishop um and we can make an
argument about which one is better right
when you're trying to evaluate like an
imbalance like that you want to think of
the value of the pieces not just in a
vacuum but in the position so Bishops
thrive in positions with open lines
right where they can attack on Long
diagonals across the board you also want
to note the color complex with the
bishop so by this point where we're in a
middle game or maybe even an end game
noticing like okay well are blacks
pieces on dark squares mostly or light
squares or is it mixed CU if all my
pieces are on light squares this bishop
is just useless and if all my pieces are
on dark squares it maybe is a monster um
versus Knights prefer positions that are
more closed right where the Bishops
can't navigate as cleanly across the
board um but in this case I don't know
that any of that really matters for our
puzzle it's just something good to think
about for the
material um okay so the first thing to
look at is kind of our forcing moves
right Pawn takes Bishop but I think we
can pretty clearly establish that this
isn't so good because there's a pin on
that pawn right and even if there's
ideas of like are we going to maybe
promote in time we are always one move
too short right so we can imagine if
Pawn takes Rook takes Rook takes Rook
takes we're not threatened of a back
rank so we don't have to worry about
that but we do have to worry that even
if we get a pawn to the second rank um
The Rook can always stop it right so if
we take the Rook can just go all the way
back and if we push a little trickier
right where the Rook now can't just come
back because it gets taken uh we can
still just put the Rook behind the pawn
and because we've lost all of our Rooks
as black White's totally fine there so
we can't try any trading Shenanigans the
other move that a lot of people here are
suggesting is Knight to
F4 this also looks very good it's also a
forcing move right the most forcing we
can be most of the time is like a check
um or a capture but this move is a
threat right we're threatening to take a
a rook with a knight which is a win
material situation you don't really want
to let that happen unless you have to as
the opponent um so that feels good it
also feels good that we're adding a
Defender to this Rook so now maybe our
Pawn's not pinned and we have the
opportunity to take over here so this
looks really good the question is
how does white respond do they have any
moves they can play that cause us a
problem3 D2 okay Rook D3 to
D2 reason I say that is
because well let me ask you why they
don't let's start with that so why
what's wrong with uh because it looks
like this the point of this move is
we've now piled three pieces on and
there's only two Defenders so why
doesn't that work anymore if they just
take
because MH we have a nasty Fork um and
whether you do it right away or start
trading first I'm not sure the nuances
of which one might be better I'd have to
look closer but we have this really
beautiful Fork so the knight's just kind
of a monster on this Square it's
defending it's attacking and it's making
a major threat this is very strong so
the question then is okay well what if
they don't take the bait and just back
off
and yeah Zach I think you have the right
idea right so there's something
essential that's changed as we kind of
pointed out before the fact now that our
Knight defends The Rook means our Pawn
isn't pinned so we're actually with
Knight F4 we're making two arguably
three threats one is we're threatening
if they capture we're threatening to
make this
Fork that's kind of the potential one
because they don't have to capture but
the two threats that are very real one
we're threatening to just take a rook
and two by defending the Rook ourselves
we're threatening to take the bishop so
if they just play their waiting move
right and I think we can say this is
safely the move uh they just decide to
move the bishop out of the way and we're
just going to take this and they can
take back but now we're up
material had they instead played Rook
tod2 then yeah our idea is just we just
capture the bishop and even if they win
the pawn back still we're a material in
this end game uh I also love this
position as black because this is a
position where a trade is forced there's
they might not have to trade everything
but they can't get out of it right
because if they just move the Rook away
well now we're just winning a piece so
they have to at at least trade one of
their Rooks and then they can kind of
figure it out from there and anytime you
can liquidate material in a position
where you're ahead is going to be
good um and again I feel really
confident with everyone's assessments
there but we can always check against
the computer and yeah so dakes is the
move and had they taken then yes this
Fork is the
problem okay let's look at our next one
again hopefully this is helpful to you
the we're trying to learn from puzzles
and you know learn from these positions
but also just the process of when you
encounter a puzzle or just encounter any
position what kinds of things do you
want to look out for to try and solve it
so here we have black to move White's
last move was Pawn to G3 which is really
interesting because there's like a
threat of taking a rook and lots of
stuff going on so this is one of the
ones that I even like to back up and say
okay well why did you play this
move why do we think white played G3 is
their last
move yeah there's a back rank right if
if they don't this king is stuck right
it doesn't matter that this is a knight
and not a pawn it it's still impeding
the king's View and so if you place any
other move then just Queen to D1 is M so
G3 is opening up an escape square and
creating now this
threat so how do we continue from
here yeah a few moves are jumping out
right so again what I'm noticing first
let's the material is three pawns versus
four pawns got Knight and Bishop versus
knight and Bishop two Rooks versus two
Rooks and a queen our pieces are kind of
terrible truthfully like we I think we
locked into this position because our
pieces are not coordinated at all um or
not developed at all I should say but
the pieces we have on the board are very
coordinated um because of some maybe
King safety
issues so it doesn't really matter funny
enough that our Rook is attacked it
doesn't matter that all of White's
pieces save this Rook are pretty active
um we have some problems and the
problems are you're suggesting Bishop
H3 what's your
idea
yeah
B yes uh yes really nice so the problem
with this is It's all about King safety
and it's this back rank threat right
back ranks are you know again often just
you see like in the books the three
pawns and the King but the important
thing with a back rank is to say okay
well the king's on the back row that
matters because if we can attack the
whole back row and there's nowhere
forward for him or her or it to safely
step um then it's Checkmate so it
doesn't matter if it's three pawns it
doesn't matter if it's some of their own
pieces it doesn't matter if it's our
pieces attacking those squares it all
kind of counts as that back rank family
and so Bishop H3 is a really beautiful
move because if you block then your
Bishop steps in the way and takes up
that square and we can now call
Checkmate had the king step to the the
side then it's the same thing you can
call Checkmate actually in two different
ways uh because there's our Bishop
controlling this Square now and sadly
this Knight is actually doing a terrible
job of Defense because if it's not in
the way then uh the queen can actually
maybe jump in now it doesn't matter so
much because of our Bishop but had they
Cho chosen to block right if I guess
this still doesn't matter because they
can't hit it so their pieces are just
really discoordinated which is kind of
funny
uh okay let's jump to our next one here
okay it's white to move and black just
took a piece on B5 with the
queen so again feel free to suggest
moves or just comments on what seemed to
be the relevant piece of the position
that we should kind of hone in on here
right in this position Queen D6 has been
suggested this is a nice check
right
um and actually I think that's just
straight up check me that I look at it
more so Queen D6 sometimes check it
might be mate right this is a good rule
of thumb to follow uh especially if you
are low on time just play a check right
might be mate and at least that way you
avoid stalemate that's kind of funny um
so we don't have to spend a ton of time
here but important thing to notice right
is again King safety right this king is
you know it feels safe it's on the back
rank it's got some Defenders around it
um but our pieces like our Knight is
just controlling so much space by this
opponent's king it's really hard to
avoid that so King safety is not just
about you know an opponent's king being
exposed as I said before it's also about
our pieces being active and able to make
threats and yeah Queen D6 is a very
funny Checkmate in one just covering
every Square really
beautifully not too much else I think
needs to be said
here all right this position it is black
to move and Rook to F2 was the last move
played defending this Knight that is
under
threat
yeah and again this is like a harder one
to see I think if you're like really a
beginner is to say well if Rook takes um
this looks so crazy because you're like
well why would I ever sacrifice a rook
for a knight and again uh the thing with
these positions the way to find this
more organically is to again notice
these kind of signals so one I noticed
the the position of the King right it
looks relatively safe but we do have a
move that calls check Knight to F3
anytime you have a move we also have uh
Rook to C1 so anytime you have a move
that calls check doesn't mean the king
is in danger per se right there's plenty
of times where you can call check and it
doesn't mean anything but it's something
to be aware of to say if I needed to
make an attack real quick I could and
that's quite valuable in a lot of these
positions um and then we notice well
what are the reasons I can't do this
well one The Rook defends and two the
Knight defends right so the Knight can
just
take but when you see that those are the
only problems with that move and we have
the ability with a capture right a
forcing move to lure a piece to uh the
opponent's like to a square you want
this is called I believe attraction
where you attract a piece to a
undesirable Square
then we can find these really beautiful
tactics where in one move you can see
this quite obviously right it's so
simple when you're like oh um I just see
the pattern there's a beautiful Knight
Fork right
here but it's harder to see like it's a
lot harder to see in this position even
though it's really just one move away
that's because there's a lot of clutter
on this position right we get rid of
both of these pieces and everything
clears up but starting to look for those
signals I think it's really really
useful okay uh we have time for a
handful more so let's give it a shot it
is white to move and Rook to C5 was the
last move played by
black what seems important to notice
here there's a few things that
immediately jump out at me but I'm
actually not seeing the obvious
immediate solution which is
good yeah I think you have the right
idea Zach but what do we notice what's
important to notice
here King's going to Center on the board
right so my first thought was is there a
Checkmate right um I'm looking and
saying okay well I control a lot of
these squares right uh and you have
pieces on some of the other ones the
problem is there's not really there's
two problems one there's not a great way
to call check and two this King also has
this Escape score that seems kind of
hard to deal with um so like we have
some checks but it didn't seem like
we're actually going to find a Checkmate
uh from this right Black's Rooks are
enough to hold us off so the next thing
we look for is unprotected pieces right
that's another one of our signals or
alignments or some of these other things
um but uh Zach in the chat made this
really good point that this Rook is
perilously uh
protected right there there's different
ways to express this idea but and you
can get a deeper dive in my kind of
lecture on tactical signals but or
hanging pieces but the idea here is when
you're looking for a piece that is
unprotected sometimes you can also look
for a piece that is insufficiently
protected and what we mean by that is
look at this Rook on D6 no pieces are
protecting it so but also no pieces are
attacking it so it's just kind of like a
neutral piece
if we had a way to attack it quickly
with like a forcing tactic or something
then it's a potential liability for
black but this counts in the same way
because even though it has one protector
it also has one attacker already on it
so if we add that extra attacker or move
that extra Defender tactically then the
result is the same we can treat it like
an unprotected
piece and because we have this really uh
beautiful way to this is I think the
opposite so last time we talked about
attraction where we pulled a piece to a
square that was undesirable so we could
punish that piece in this case we're
going to do deflection which we pull a
piece to an undesirable square away from
another key piece right in the last one
it was this uh we pulled this Rook to an
undesirable Square to Fork
it and win that piece in this
case uh oops this one oh
no no I should have solved it first um
but in that position if you can kind of
recall it in your mind the idea was we
can push the pawn up I think the King
was like here we pushed the pawn up to
attack the king and the King was going
to be pulled away not defending that
Rook anymore and we would then take it
sorry I didn't solve that one but you
guys got the answer here okay this is
our position it is black to move and
White's last move was A4 which is I kind
of revealing to me that either white
sees nothing else good to do in this
position or they see that well I have a
threat of just winning the game if you
don't stop me so stop
me so let's stop them what can we do
from
here all right so Rook E2 has been
suggested what is the idea with this
move okay
why
yeah yes so Rook to E2 is a really nice
tactical idea so this is actually a Fork
um it doesn't look like it but it is and
the idea here is to think uh we often
think of like a fork as oh I'm attacking
two pieces like I'm attacking a king and
I'm attacking a a rook or I'm attacking
two Rooks or something like that uh
but you can also attack key squares and
uh the back rank here counts as that key
square right if we have a way to
infiltrate the back rank safely uh this
king is just dead in the water and and
so in with Rook to E2 we are forking the
queen and E1 now there is a complication
here because the argument is oh well if
we just pull the queen away from the e
file then we can just play queen or Rook
either way to the square but what if
after Rook to E2 say they play something
like Queen to B4 which defends the back
rank
yeah the pro so there's two problems one
it's this Fork right where we Fork the
back Rank and the queen but there's a
second problem is this queen is
overworked she has to now defend both
the back Rank and there's already this
nice thread of our pieces lined up and
dominating the second uh second Rank and
so we have a threat of just playing
Queen takes G2 and just giving the kiss
of death to the white king here and so
whatever they
choose in this case they just choose to
sacrifice the queen which again I mean
this is actually the best move it makes
sense by the computer because now we
still have to prove we can win an end
game of rook and Knight and pawn versus
queen so like this is the practically
right way to play um we should still win
as black here without too much trouble
because the Rook has to guard the back
rank row and help navigate this pawn and
there's no way this Knight is
contributing
much but again we can see that had this
not been played right there's no way to
defend the back rank securely because
now we switch our threats to the second
Rank and if just some other move if if
the queen maintains defense of this Pawn
then now we can either drop the queen or
The Rook probably the queen is more
stylish so let's do that one in order to
get our back
rank okay our next example here it looks
like very little has shifted um just
back to an end game just Rooks and pawns
on the board and white has played Pawn
on to D5 threatening to infiltrate very
very close to our uh our back
rank how should we continue as
black so uh yeah Zach is arguing again
for a check and in this case to exchange
the Rooks and then we can even take on
D5 now the question is why would you
want to exchange the Rooks in this
position right it's very clear that
that's a possibility right but why would
that be
helpful cuz actually it looks like I'm
not sure our King might be close enough
to defend the pawn but White's King also
might be close enough to get back to
it we have a better structure um I agree
with
that and even if we can't you know say
this one we definitely can win this Pawn
we probably can do both but White's got
to deal with this problem with his past
Pawn so in these types of end games
where you have like a king and rook and
some pawns versus King rook and some
pawns often the winner is going to be
who's more active in this case white is
arguably more active right their maybe
their Rook isn't doing so much at the
moment but their pawns are farther
forward their King is certainly more
active than ours and so if we can force
them to give some of that up right if we
can trade the Rooks we have to lure
their King all the way to the edge of
the board to defend then their King
loses its activity it also loses the
defense of this pawn and we have time to
activate our own King so in this
position I think liquidation makes a lot
of sense and if we don't if we try and
like if we just get greedy and take this
Pawn now we might be in a lot of trouble
after something like D6 maybe maybe Pawn
takes but probably just pushing um this
looks a little scary to me so yeah I
love this idea let's give it a shot Rook
2 H five four check we
trade and now we take on D5 and again if
you get to this position and you're like
well what's the point of the how am I
winning this game um feel free to
continue to puzzle it out from here feel
free to use computer assistance to help
you understand the position um it seems
like
yeah it seems like white might be
getting to this Pawn
first so let's see let's take a look
what's the re oh because we can also run
so we can force white to lure their King
farther away this makes sense and we can
also just straight up win this one so
again if you don't understand a position
totally that's fine I just recommend
yeah using uh using your resources to to
give it a check all right uh we probably
have time for one or two more so let's
see if we can end on a good note here it
is black to move white has just played
Queen to F4 what do we notice
here right we can look at the material
looks like one two three four white I
think is up a
pawn but it's a doubled Pawn but they
also have a passed Pawn that seems
valuable to know a whole bunch of
alignment going on on the f file here we
got Rook Queen Rook Knight a bunch of
Pawns so there's maybe some stuff to
notice with that um someone says Queen
is undefended this is an important thing
to notice I think often that doesn't
matter so much because when we're
looking for like tactics of is the queen
defended or not that only ever matters
in a situation where we're looking at a
queen trade right because if the queen
is attacked by any piece other than a
queen most of the time it doesn't want
to get captured at all and so it's
always just going to move but in this
case because our Queens are kind of in
this same alignment that could matter
right because it doesn't it doesn't so
much matter if we're able to you know
trade Queens but if we can attack it
without them having time to respond that
could be quite valuable so I'm noticing
yeah I agree that seems important uh we
have to be a little bit careful of our
back rank we have enough Defenders right
now but there is you know a check to
watch out
for so that seems to be the immediate
stuff to notice and with that what do we
want to
do okay Knight to H4 check seems pretty
strong right what's the
idea the
check theen
yes yeah and that basically sums it up
so we have a discovered attack because
of our alignment here we have a
discovered attack if we move this Knight
The Queen Is hit and we have a place we
can move it safely right uh our Queen
defends so we're able to recapture
here uh but even if they choose not to
do that because this queen is not
defended we can take and the queen
actually will get defended in this line
sometimes right if the King goes up but
it still doesn't matter because it's not
defended enough we have two pieces of
Firepower against just the king and so
we can continue to step
forward oh and that's also a Checkmate I
didn't realize that but our night covers
the exit that's kind of funny all right
let's finish out with one more good one
we won't analyze this one super deep but
let's put everything we've learned to
the test it is black to move what should
we
do
I have some ideas but I'm not sold on
this
one yeah some suggestions that we just
push a three the question is like this
Pawn is close to promotion if we can
make a new queen or force it to the pawn
to trade off for like The Rook or
something we're doing well question is
does White have any resource to try and
stop our Pawn promotion
here the only move I think that looks a
little challenging is maybe Queen takes
C4 and now the queen is preparing to
defend the Rook to go to A4 and kind of
cut us off so do we have any good way to
respond to that
that okay Zach makes a good point we
always have our eye on this E5 Pawn so
if the Queen ever goes away we can
always take this with check that looks
good I don't know if it's enough to win
but it looks really
good
A3 Rook
takes
interesting yeah I wonder if you have it
with Queen back to
F5 we make if we can make our Queen
right we take take but do you
have yeah you make a good
argument well I'll tell you
what uh we have Queen take on E5 but
what if the Rook takes yeah I don't
think
that
all right people are saying a lot of
ideas and I would love to continue
exploring this position but I also want
to leave time for our Grandmaster and
residence uh melik to give it a shot so
let's just see what happens let's push
A3 computer likes that Queen takes on C4
seems like maybe we just take on E5
check no we continue to push and now we
take oh we just make a queen and defend
yeah that's smart that's
funny you know so even the I'm not a pro
but even people like me mess these
puzzles up and it's very funny so if you
saw that in the chat well well done
please stick around thank you for coming
to beginner breakdown but please stick
around for our grandmaster's choice with
Grandmaster melik uh we're super excited
to have him here uh winner of us senior
Champs so uh hope to have you all stick
around and have a great
[Music]
evening
y